China's military might on show at a
parade last year with some weapons seen
for the first time in October analysts
said China's technological advances were
almost unprecedented and new research is
revealing just how many of these weapons
are being produced by Beijing and a
dramatic shift from a decade ago when it
had to buy most of its munitions I think
it's very important information for us
and the world because we know that of
course China used to rely on importing
weapons from Russia but we see now that
it can almost completely build and
produce its weapons for its own military
and we also see that the industry is at
a point where other countries are
demanding its weapons the Stockholm
International Peace Research Institute
says China's now the second-biggest
arms manufacturer in the world behind
the US and with Russia in third place
there have been a number of shifts in
military policy within China first off
they've reduced over that period almost
600,000 troops but they put more money
into MA during the army the two aircraft
carriers are in production one they had
bought those are big-ticket items the
size of China's industry has been
largely a mystery with Beijing keeping
reliable data secret but the Institute
has now been able to look into four
major Chinese companies and says three
of them would be in the top 10 global
arms producers remember although China
may be rising in the ranks of
manufacturers in terms of arms exporters
that it's a very very small amount
compared to the US Russia and EU
Beijing's production prowess is in
demand it's estimated to be selling
billions of dollars worth of munitions
every year largely to Pakistan
Bangladesh and Myanmar a lot of the
buyers of Chinese weapons are very much
more friendly towards the Chinese
government it's also the case that they
cannot certainly ascertain weapons from
Western producers such as the UK or
Germany or the US and such rely on China
to
use or to provide less sophisticated and
sometimes less expensive weapons to be
used for their specific purposes in 2018
1.8 trillion dollars were spent on
weapons across the globe the highest
since the end of the Cold War with the
research pointing to increased spending
from Washington and Beijing annex II
Ryan
al-jazeera